vandals and said detective I know needed
again for the Alaska
come on the lake Christine I once wrote
in a report my job is my hobby
it's the same with my team they're all
women they're all totally committed to
their job and they love the variety of
work it's fun Aberhart Boonton wolf is
skip of this ship
his wife Kirsten is also part of the
team things don't always go smooth
depends on the women yeah it has to do
with the women the crew has to get along
and Mather and he's the sort of
balancing element he has to treat all
the women equally if not they'll be
trouble
Yeah right the ship has taken a detour
off the Rhine to Dortmund port to pick
up a thousand tons of scrap for a steel
works in France most of their jobs
involve transporting coal steel or
gravel every year around two hundred
million tons of goods are shipped down
the Rhine when the river water level is
low the captain has to watch his vessels
weight to ensure it doesn't run aground
the journey takes six days with their
cars and living quarters also on board
this is our living room it's small but
cozy we have a TV and a stereo
everything this is the eat-in kitchen
with air conditioning a dishwasher and
washing machine just like on land this
is where the dog lives and our bedroom
yeah this is where we shower with hot
and cold running water out of season
final cuts off it's lunch time while the
skipper takes a break
Lisa notng takes the wheel she joined
the crew five years ago
she's 23 years old and in two weeks time
she'll be taking her captain's exams
why should I apply for a job in a bank
it wouldn't interest me and I probably
wouldn't be good enough in math to be
accepted I decided to get a job where
people need me
the rhein remains a vital waterway for
the region with hundreds of commercial
ships plying the waters every day
captain Boonton horf has a 13 hour
journey ahead of him today the crew have
been up since 5:00 this morning
they don't sail at night
do sport the biggest inland port in the
world
here they rejoin the Rhine before
heading upstream to Cologne with her
captain's exams coming up Lisa noting
has to know every Bend and every tricky
current and depth in the Rhine
she and her mentor have plans for the
future the skipper is not far from
retirement now so the plan is for me to
gradually take charge of the ship but
not all at once
so he'll be gone for one day then for
two and eventually he'll be gone
altogether aim aha
Booton wolf comes from a long line of
boatman with over 30 years experience
under his belt he's an old hand the
problem is he says there are too many
captains and too little tonnage the
freights are still too few but at least
the fuel oil prices aren't too high what
you fear is them going up again and not
enough orders coming in we're doing okay
but we need to set money aside for
modernization and repairs that could be
difficult
the skipper hopes to pick up a new load
to make the journey back worth it orders
tend to come in at short notice by phone
I just as well that his wife has a
regular job on land three days a week
that's been the family team set up for
the past 20 years but don't they get on
each other's nerves sometimes rarely
yeah we do get on grades 99% of the time
it's probably considering how crammed
that is here I know when to back down
and then it works after an 11 hour
journey they arrive in Cologne
two hours earlier than expected leezar
noting can't imagine a better job it can
get stressful when we have to cast off
right away or get to a particular port
we can't go any faster than 10 km/h so
you sit there and think okay so they're
stressed but since you can't go any
faster just enjoy the peace and calm
it's just great another working day
gradually comes to a close tomorrow
they'll continue their journey to
Coblentz another four days and they'll
be docking in France